in what's up my man how you doing today
didn't I see you at a shack party last
year during the super good I imagine I
know you sure did
there's probably not a lot of parties
you won't see me yet especially in Miami
and I'm always there you know that yeah
I feel like there might be a party or
two down there and I am there I mean I
need to brace myself for what that
experience is gonna be like looking good
well is actually Miami is close to
Jacksonville so that's where I want to
turn here or start with you first with
Jalen Ramsey the the latest update on
the Jalen Ramsey situation with the
Jaguars what's what's the latest well
owner shot con talked to a reporter
today from the street which is a Wall
Street based publication I believe at
least I hope they seem to be on the
floor of the New York Stock Exchange and
he said he expects Ramsey to play this
week which is very interesting which is
not something I had heard before and
he's basing this on owner shot ton as
his conversation with Ramsey Tuesday
when Ramsey came into the building and
the two had a heart-to-heart all this is
fine I just have not heard from Ramsey
or someone close to him that he actually
is going to play and and that's what I
think gives me a little bit of pause
because this situation has always been
nothing I imagined or anticipated it has
been way more complicated way more
nuanced then than anything I remember
and you know I just would like to make
sure the Ramsey's actually playing
before we all kind of talk about it
because as you know he has worked
himself back very slowly yes from this
back injury so let's see what it would
see what happened in this heart-to-heart
do you think that a contract possibly
was talked about would maybe chicon
extending that way we're going to take
care of you we want you here or what
what possibly was discussed for him to
think that you know I feel good about
playing again with the Jaguars well I
think the main thing is I don't get the
sense the contract would do it I mean
you know Jalen Ramsey and he sort of
explained this on his on his podcast
he's going to get paid he's not a guy
who's like pay me pay me pay me
you need to you know you need to give me
what I'm worth or else what he's just
he's just not like that he's going to
make a lot of money he's gonna make it
whatever he gets a new contract he's
gonna be the highest-paid corner in the
NFL as in obvious as he should I don't
get the sense he's clamoring for a new
contract right now in fact you know
history shows he's better served waiting
anyway because the money is just going
to get higher I think it was more just
and how obviously it wasn't there but I
think it was more just you know an
explanation for why the owner doesn't
want to move because you know at some
point if the owner doesn't want to trade
you you know you're not getting traded
and I think that's kind of where where
this situation is and I would imagine
that's what was explained to Jalen Rose
NFL Network insider Ian Rapoport joining
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison fill
it in for rich you know last time I saw
you we were down in Napa at the Napa
Valley Marriott watching a joint
practice between the Rams and the
Raiders and the talk around the Rams
camp was that Tiger Lee will be on a
pitch count we'll see how they utilize
him early on now he looks to be is
pretty healthy I guess going in terms of
last week starting to look like he was
catching his stride and he shows up on
the injury report right now what's the
latest that you hear from Todd Gurley
and this mysterious quadriceps injury
that came out of nowhere
yeah I think it didn't come out of
nowhere but it did catch the Rams by
surprise a little bit because you know
it sounded like when he left on Thursday
not gonna say he was fine but they
thought he was gonna be okay and now
it's something where you know to my
understanding like his status is really
his dad's is really up in the air I
don't know you know I don't know if he's
gonna play on Sunday I really don't I
wish I did I know they're getting the
other guys ready to play and so you know
we'll kind of see where it all goes I
also know that not only the Rams
confident and the guys behind them but
they are okay in doing everything they
can to make sure that grill is ready
late
season so like if they needed to be
cautious and not play him and weak
whatever this is seven or whatever yes
then I think they would be okay with
that so we'll see what the final
determination is but it's not a
situation where everyone knows yeah he's
fine don't even worry about it it's not
like that well in I know who won't be
playing this season not list is this
week but this season vantes Burfict the
suspension uphill by Derrick Brooks the
arbitrator in this situation so what's
next for I guess Vontae is perfect there
is no more appeals process what
ultimately does the deciding factor on
keeping him out this season yeah I mean
you know we have not gotten a decision
from from Derrick Brooks the third-party
arbitrator I know everyone thinks that
the NFL it's not the NFL it's the NFL in
the NFLPA jewelley appoint him as the
arbitrator and he had upheld a perfect
suspension in the past he's a good guy
there's a lot of respect for the game so
you know when Derrick Brooks uphold your
year-long suspension that is pretty no
worthy to me and I just I don't know if
he's gonna play again because he'll be
30 he's a middle linebacker he has his
history obviously we all know it you
know it does anyone want to sign him and
give him any sort of money and have him
you know it's someone else and there you
lose your middle linebacker that you
counted on
berg the whole season but this the next
time this happens you know it's probably
going to be the season two so I just I
don't know if he's going to play again I
think it's possibly cheating the last
about this perfect Ian Rapoport the NFL
Network insider joining the Rich Eisen
show Kirk Morrison here filling in for
rich and so Ian we we knew early this
week the key card
did not work for one Jay Gruden or I
think it worked initially and it was
declined later on so there's a coaching
vacancy already it worked at about 4:00
in the morning and then after that not
yet but there's an opening now with the
Washington Redskins but yet they still
have a season to play they still got a
bunch of games left how do they handle
the rest of the season how do you
think they're gonna handle Dewayne
Haskins kind of moving forward I would
say it sounds like they like Haskins to
not do anything which you know with
Patrick mahomes is probably the best
quarterback in the NFL now he didn't do
anything as a rookie except play in week
17 I look great when he did but he
hardly played at all
I think it's okay you know that he
doesn't I think it's okay if he doesn't
play they sound like they don't want to
rush them and you know whoever the next
coach is and we know obviously now there
is gonna be another coach I'm sure it's
not going to be Bill Cowher and in there
we'll see what they end up deciding but
it does seem they're they're fine having
him wait and not play and kind of
develop slowly so they're not taking but
yet at some point I think League think
back to when the Kansas City Chiefs did
let Patrick mahomes said it was because
they had a good football team and Alex
Smith was the starting quarterback so it
was easy to kind of let a guy sit when
Alex is performing right how much longer
or what does daniel snyder do if this
team continues to lose and yet their
best option probably at quarterback
you're forcing him to sit yeah I mean I
would say that you know them continuing
to lose is not the worst thing in the
world I mean I know you'd always sort of
like to win but them continuing to lose
is probably something that will end up
paying dividends you know for the
Washington Redskins so it doesn't make
sense just doesn't make sense to do
everything you can to win right now it's
just the reality of the draft system I
know it's still early in the season in
and one coaching high our opening is
already available who do you probably
think is probably mixed up on that
possible getting out the rest of the
season
I think you know a lot of it depends on
what happens in the field I think you
know people are watching the Falcons I
think that's that's one my colleague
beyond Sandler said some stuff earlier
in the week kind of indicating that you
know he's obviously a Falcons legend
indicating that you know he he's sort of
thought that the Falcons are in some
trouble I would agree I don't know how
immediate it is but um you know that's a
situation where I'm definitely kind of
watching the Falcons to potentially
being next there you know
look I'm looking at right now and I'm
thinking is there a situation outside of
Dan Quinn or anybody else in terms of
the coaching circles is Zach Taylor we
talked him a little bit earlier with the
Bengals and now it kind of circles
around with AJ green with them being
Owen five right now - cincinnati bengals
is there a point that we may not see AJ
green in a Cincinnati Bengals uniform
probably by the end of the year I have
not gotten I got a run after this
inducing TV but I have not gotten that
indication at all about the Bengals
trading AJ Green and to me he is a huge
part of their franchise he personally
has been quoted as saying that he wants
to be left as Gerald which the place is
a entire career in the organization you
know if they decide to try and they
train I just you know I have never heard
from anyone that they want to trade or
even would entertain entertain offers
for AJ green plus you know if you think
about it logically
he's a 31 year old receiver who hasn't
played all season ended last year with a
lower leg injury you know I'm not sure
the value is going to be great for the
Bengals anyway I mean who's gonna offer
a premium pick the 31 year old receiver
who has been hobbled the last couple
years I think that's a good question as
well yeah I know you got a runny and I
appreciate the time as always all right
Thank You Rodney man take care all good
you know wrap report NFL Network insider
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app